both the trump and biden campaigns are
also making their final push to voters
here in nevada
orkomana joins us live near the las
vegas strip tonight to share how they're
encouraging
everyone to make their voices heard orco
well sasha both republicans and
democrats say that everyone who is able
to
should go out and vote election day is
just two days away and with the
presidential race so close here in
nevada
every vote counts
everything is at stake donald trump jr
making a final push to nevada voters at
an indoor rally sunday in las vegas
he says his father president trump is
the best person to re-energize the
economy create peace in the middle east
and take on big pharma
so donald trump is fighting those
battles for the american people and i
think they've seen the results
i spoke to trump jr in a one-on-one
interview and he tells me he wants
everyone to go to the polls on election
day but he's still casting doubt on the
mail-in voting process despite no
widespread evidence of voter fraud in
the u.s
or nevada you think they're they're
checking each one of these things
they're going through all of that
how come they're finding ballots in some
states in ditches uh amazingly enough
all these absentee ballots from the
military which they know are going to
skew heavily towards trump those are the
ones that magically disappear and we
know that there's still a lot of work to
do
the nevada state democratic party
holding their own event sunday to
mobilize voters governor steve sisolak
and congresswoman susie lee
encouraging volunteers to get the word
out we're confident if we could just
knock on one more door
make one more phone call one more text
we're going to get to where we need to
be on tuesday
and that's what elections are about
they're about knocking doors and getting
people out to vote
the latest emerson college poll has joe
biden two points ahead of donald trump
in the silver state but the trump team
has all hands on deck to try to win
nevada's vote
well i'm here with two days left so it's
obviously a pretty good priority
and to watch my full one-on-one
interview with donald trump jr just head
to our website 8newsnow.com
and here's some helpful and helpful
information for those of you who have
not voted yet
you can register to vote and cast your
ballot at any one
of the more than 100 polling locations
on election day
and if you are in line by 7 pm you will
be able to vote
reporting live near the las vegas strip
tonight orco mana 8 news now